here in this country the average price
of gasoline jumped another six cents
overnight to four dollars and 32 cents a
gallon as part of the war that's 59
cents higher than last week because fuel
is more expensive other travel costs are
going up too errol barnett is at
washington reagan's national airport
errol good morning
hey there nancy good morning great to
see you yeah you can expect most of your
travel costs to jump some airlines now
warning of reduced capacity as a result
from the increase in jet fuel costs
which will of course mean your airline
tickets will cost more as well oh and
yes you can expect your trip to the
airport in a ride share that will also
be more expensive
i think it's like outrageous across the
country americans are feeling the pinch
at the pump 85 dollars just for this
time and i'm just going to use this for
what three or four days a recent poll
from aaa finding almost 60 percent
surveyed said they would make changes to
their driving habits with gas above four
dollars per gallon if it reaches five
dollars per gallon as it has in some
states three-quarters said they would
need to adjust their lifestyle emanuel
who did not want to provide his last
name is an uber and lyft driver in
washington high prices forcing him to
add four extra hours to his 10 hour
shifts each day sounds really grueling
if you're going to have to work a
14-hour day to earn the same amount of
money how does that make you feel oh
really it makes you feel sometimes like
you are sick but you are tired not sick
and air travelers are also seeing high
prices at a time when covert
restrictions are being eased and there's
pent up travel demand cbs news senior
travel editor peter greenberg says
airline prices are up 20 percent and
will likely creep higher partly due to
jet fuel costs which are also increasing
that's prompted alaska and allegiant
airlines to cut some flights you have a
big problem here with your cutting roots
your cutting capacity and your
increasing fares how bad is it going to
be this summer when you see that
happening right now
now the universal message from travel
analysts is that with increased summer
demand approaching now is the time to
book your tickets for summer travel
hurry up and make those plans with your
friends and families you know we've been
talking about ride shares and airline
tickets but you can expect these price
hikes across the board from rental cars
to cruise ships to buses all of it nate
will be more expensive in the weeks
ahead
whether by plane train or automobile
it's going to cost us more yeah errol
thank you